Community gathered to mourn Tyree
Nichols at his funeral yesterday they
were joined by vice president Kamala
Harris and the families of other victims
of police violence Nichols as you know
died three weeks ago days after a
traffic stop led to a brutal beating by
police officers Lee's Preston is in
Memphis with more on his funeral
services Elise good morning to you
Gail good morning to you violence
against black men has been a defining
element here in Memphis this same city
where civil rights icon Dr Martin Luther
King Jr was assassinated in 1968. 55
years later the city still seems to be
grappling with its Legacy of racial
Injustice
Tyree was a beautiful person
and for this to happen to him it's just
unimaginable in a series of
heart-wrenching tear-filled speeches
Tyree nichols's family expressed sorrow
beyond words I see the world showing him
love
and fighting for
all I want is my baby brother back they
were joined in Memphis by a civil rights
Legend the Reverend Al Sharpton I know
what I saw on the tape
and the tape speaks for itself who
invoked Dr Martin Luther King Jr's death
in that same city 55 years ago in the
city
that displayed the dream
what has happened to the dream family
attorney Ben Crum suggested nichols's
death could be a turning point in this
call to action
we established his legacy vice president
Kamala Harris who was also in attendance
made an impassioned plea for restarting
negotiations on federal police reform
which stalled in Congress after the
death of George Floyd we demand that
Congress passed the George Floyd Justice
and policing act Joe Biden will sign it
Floyd's family also attended the funeral
yesterday alongside other prominent
families of victims of police violence
and nichols's mother had a message for
them there should be no other child that
should suffer the way my son and all the
other parents see here have lost their
children
we need to get that bill passed
among the crowd of nearly 1 000 mourners
were the mothers of Eric Garner and
Brianna Taylor meanwhile the President
and Vice President will meet with the
Congressional Black Caucus at the white
house today to discuss the George Floyd
Justice in policing act David
Elise in Memphis thank you Elise